I definitely want to ask you I've
recently spoken to Lorenzo about the
Transformers franchise and Transformers
one and I spoke to Scarlett yesterday
you voice Optimus before Optimus you
know
um what was your reasoning for signing
on for Transformers one uh and what was
your take when you saw some of the
animation from ilm because Lorenzo tells
me and Scarlett even said it looks
incredible yeah
uh it it does it looks incredible
um I love the script uh it was one where
I was not sure I hadn't done an
animation before and then I mentioned to
my kids and I went oh yeah that's
awesome
um and so it's it's it's been really fun
putting down some of the dialogue and
and waving it in with the you know early
days of the animation
um
it's cool it's exciting it's it's you
know Optimus Prime come on
come on and I don't know if you're
allowed to but are you doing it with
your accent no I'll do it um I mean we
talked about this the Optimus Prime that
you you know that you hear on the screen
um in the films
isn't all the mature you know this has
been around for many many many many
years
um this is the sort of origin story so
it's the younger those of him and um so
there's sort of hints and and colorings
that hopefully uh resonate enough with
the Optimus Prime we know but it is a
youthful uh version of him and different
but he won't be Australian right okay
the I the ilm hasn't done an animated
movie since Rango and Rango is
incredible so because ilm is doing it
I'm over the moon why because
he's voicing afterwards